good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the bd2k training coordinating
center based at the university of
southern california I'd like to welcome
you to our big data to knowledge guide
to the fundamentals of data science and
today we're absolutely delighted to have
nils Galan Borg speaking on the subject
of data visualization tools and
communications Nils is a associate
professor in the department of
biomedical informatics at Harvard
Medical School in his research and
worked on the subject of developing
novel tools to visualize 3d genomic
information as well as heterogeneous
data from large-scale cancer genomic
studies he's a co-investigator for the
4d nucleon network data and coordination
and integration Center hosted at Harvard
Medical School and he's the co-founder
former general chair and current
steering committee chair of bio viz
which is the symposium on biological
data visualization is the co-founder of
biz v sorry vis be the annual workshop
on visualizing biomedical data and
co-chairs the policy working group for
the 4d nucleon network which is an NIH
Common Fund project he served on the
program Committees of several
international bioinformatics and
visualization conferences and held
multiple editorial roles including his
current role as associate editor of BMC
bioinformatics he's contributed to the
points of view data visualization column
in Nature Methods
and we are absolutely delighted to have
you Nils and we look forward to your
presentation
go hi everyone my apologies for being
muted for a second apparently the
software just detected a new hardware
and put a dialog on my screen that I
didn't see let's try this again I hope
you can all see my screen and thank you
very much for the invitation and for the
nice introduction so I'm here today to
give you an important warning an
important message if people try to sell
any fancy
visualization tools that have something
about 3d exciting colorful interactive
scatter plots you should be careful and
have a very close look at why this
scatter plot is in 3d and if that makes
any sense at all so the title of the
talk today about tools for data
visualization and communication um I
thought a little more about as I first
thought I'm going to tell you about all
these exciting cutting-edge tools that
we have for different data types but
then I realized that bd2k is such a
broad audience and there's so many
people doing so many exciting things
there's so many different data types
I couldn't possibly cover all of them in
this hour that we have today so I
decided instead to interpret tools as
tools that you can use to figure out
what is a good visualization tool and
what is not and also then how we can use
visualization ability to communicate so
I'm going to cover those things and
quick overview off the outline here for
today I want to start with use cases for
data visualization and how these
elimination works now I'll talk a little
bit about how we use visualization to
encode data for visualizations I'll talk
about common mistakes that we make all
the time and then you see all over the
place once we know that there are
mistakes and finally I want to emphasize
how we can move the realization for
communication so use cases for data
visualization let
start with a question man how does data
visualization work to begin with and
this sentence might be more than you
expect it's visualization users
perception to free up cognition what the
heck does that mean
so I'll give you an example here is the
sequence of human insulin but these are
110 amino acids and I'm asking you is
there a problem in the sequence and
those who do not know what a purlin is
it to pee in the sequence and well if
you're gonna start doing right now
unless you know that there is going in
there you will start to scan the
sequence sequential you start at the top
left and scan through why I show you
this and ask you is there a program in
this sequence you'd say yes right away
without scanning anything so here we're
using something pre-attentive processing
and I'll get into that in a second what
that means but you can use visualization
to really make information jump out and
this came to be using color can code a
letter in the sequence and it allows us
to perceive these letters without
linearly or sequentially scanning the
scene in front of us and so this is an
example where we're using perception
rather than cognition to interpret data
and that's what utilization allows us to
do it really in a way it's it's another
term for what visualization is it's an
external cognitive aid and it allows us
to augment our working memory and I have
another example here that I think is
very very insightful so when you learn
how to multiply large numbers fourth
grade or third grade you'll you'll learn
this technique where you're adding them
up step by step
well you multiply it and then add them
up step by step so that is another
example for an external cognitive a we
using your external izing information
putting it on front of us so that we can
think about what matters and then break
the problem down and that's what we do
ligation does as well here's another
example of how that looks
you know if I give you two functions and
ask you who they intersect when they
cross zero anywhere again what you need
to do
his table you need to try to figure out
what the shape of these curves are these
functions in fact the two of them in
figure out if they might be in a second
if I just plot them you can look that up
so your your your eye beats your memory
in here and you're you're able to answer
these questions much much faster okay so
that's how data visualization works in
very basic terms now how do we use this
how can we exploit the fact that you now
can externalize things that we can
offload work through a perceptual system
so one example is and I'm going to use a
quote here that I think almost everyone
has said at some point in their life I
believe it when I see it and yeah we
don't know who really came up with that
first but it's certainly an important
question and I want to give you an
example why that mattered so why that is
related to data varieties so here's
something that many of you probably have
seen before or know about and that is
ants one support tech ants transport
dead is instead of four functions that
initial sort of inspection with some
simple summary statistics appear to be
identical all four of them have the same
name for X and the same mean I said
Marian's for X as a means for lie saying
variance of Y have the same correlation
between x and y and also the same linear
regression line so well this data set is
small so by looking at the numbers you
can see what they they are not the same
but imagine this was a data set with
hundreds or thousands or even hundreds
of thousands or millions of rows you
know you would think you have two or
four identical data sets maybe they're
not forwarding the same way if they look
different at the top let's plot the data
and see what happens
but here is an Swissport that body and
needs to see very clearly that these
functions are not to say and this is an
example of a using data visualization to
confirm an assumption that we have about
data and the trick here is that
mineralization is can be used in Waiver
it's very where it's completely unbiased
to any underlying assumptions or models
that you might be applying here and
when you do statistics and this is why
we can really explore date and look at
data in this way
and hopefully not make mistakes like we
would have made if we would have just
used some summary statistics and this is
thanks to Francis handsome who was a
state decision now another useful is the
data visualization is you know when you
ask yourself well is there is there any
any data in my are there any patterns in
my data and that is where we're using
data visualization as an exploratory
tool to generate hypotheses and we will
visualize data and then start looking
for patterns such as trends with gaps in
the day that outliers or clusters and
then start to reason about why these
things are there why is there a gap in
the lead and our measurement device not
work or is this really something that
happened was it just nothing no signal
during that time so this is this allows
us to generate hypotheses and you know
once you have a hypothesis and of course
the next step is to try to come up with
this statistic or computational approach
is to follow up on them and particularly
at large data sets but this is the first
step when we do data-driven research we
have to come up with hypotheses after we
have generated the data and that's what
the individual is this was so important
and it's getting so much more attention
these days because we need to tell those
hypotheses we're not collecting data to
test a hypothesis we just start with the
data and we need as a first step come up
with hypotheses and so that's why we're
really interested in having good
visualization approaches finally there
is a third use case for the
visualization and that is nicely
summarized by this book by Napoleon a
good sketch is better than a long speech
or also known as a picture's worth a
thousand words
and there is a wonderful example for
what that could mean and it also
involves Napoleon it's Napoleon's
biggest defeats it's a little bit ironic
Napoleon's marshal Moscow I'm sure many
of you have seen this this is a an
infographic by someone called Charles
Minard
who was a two centuries ago
and he created these these these these
figures based on on data in fact and in
this in this example you can see some
the size of opponents army marching
towards Moscow after that like brown
line or orange line that's getting
smaller and smaller and then the way
back when they were retrieving is the
black lines it gets even smaller and
they're interesting things that can
observe me or how the size of the army
sort of somewhat correlated with the
temperature drop in as well as with
situations where they have to cross
rivers that always leads to larger
losses and so this disfigures is pretty
famous aren't them going to much more
detail here now visualization you
and there are also different kind of
situations in which we use visualization
for these things so for example so we
can obviously always go back and forth
between all three options and this is in
fact what we do all the time but you
also need to be aware that for example
when you're looking at conformation
exploration this is a dialogue between a
computer and an analyst but when we
present data we have a dialogue between
an analyst and an audience so there's
some difference we use different ways of
looking at the data we have different
kind of needs for our visualizations and
I'm going to get into that and we'll
come back to this at the very end so to
begin with if you want to visualize data
we need to somehow take the values and
things I said and turn them into
something visual something brown and
this is the step where encode data for
visual representation and I want to give
you an example of why you really need to
think about how to do this and what it
matters and so there's a wonderful paper
by a colleague of mine we sell Morken
and other colleagues at Harvard who
studied visualization of arteries in the
heart to diagnose heart disease and the
paper is evaluation of arteries
violations for heart disease diagnosis
and the question that they were trying
to answer is how to best visualize
something called endothelial shear
stress that is has to be with the blood
flow through the arteries and so it is
apparently so that there are areas where
you have low English in the feeling low
stress you get buildup of plaques and
they're dangerous and where you higher
shear stress that's less risky and so
there was a new device that is able to
actually get data about where there's
high shear stress and lusciousness in
the heart arteries and they set out to
compare
sort of an existing approach of
visualizing this information to a novel
approach that they develop and what they
found is pretty striking although maybe
not surprising for someone who's
familiar with data visualization
techniques and approaches so I want to
walk you through this real quick but
traditionally the heart arteries were
visualized
as these blocks rectangles essentially
they roll that well
cut open the artery and roll it out and
then they plot on top the shear stress
measurements so high shear stress as a
sentence is better actually is indicated
by red in this example and low shear
stress is indicated by blue and that is
where where danger situation can arise
so that is one way to look at this
artery the other way is to have a 3d
model and map means shear stress values
to top of it so this is the starting
point now um I said this is a
traditional 2d projections original 3d
projection the first thing that they did
is they asked for initially what color
map would you actually like to use to
visualize this kind of information and
lo and behold the first choice of the
collisions was this rainbow color map
and the second choice was this option F
here so the reason why I picked the
rainbow color map that's what we see all
the time we know what that means
okay fair enough so let's go with this
they also explored the second choice
which was this color map which had four
little values bright red and then going
to black by by a weight firm for high
shear stress so that was the first thing
that they did then so you know for
example what you can do now is you can
map the new color map on top of a 3d
model and as you might know 3d models
are great if you have them in front of
you you can touch them it's hard
sometimes to interact with them when
you're in a computer screen because that
screen is two-dimensional so in order to
see all you know sides of this model we
have to rotate it to zoom in and out
potentially and that's all an effort
that we have to put into seeing that so
they came up with this very smart way of
representing this artery tree and that's
this one so they point in
two-dimensional representation that
still has pretty much the same
information in it that using this
two-dimensional artery present a
representation but they what they did in
addition to just shown
a rectangle with equal height across the
whole rectangle
they actually indicate the diameter off
the artery by shrinking and scaling the
height of the rectangle along the way so
we have a pretty good idea where the
arteries are wide and we have also
pretty good at here well the other grams
we simply do not have to rotate anything
you just look at the screen you can see
it so this is a wonderful situation to
be in
and you'll see in a second why that
really matter so here's a new visual
representation and what they found when
they asked set of about 20 medical
students to identify for rheumatic areas
where there's low shear stress over
regions that indicate that this patient
is at risk of heart disease series
potentially fatal problems they asked
them to look at four different types of
visualizations the one that I'm showing
right now is 2d representation with this
novel color map they asked him to look
at the same to be representation with a
rainbow color map and they also asked
him to look at the 3d projection with a
color map with the rainbow color map and
with the new color map that I'm showing
you here and the results were striking
in the sense that when we look at the
percentage of areas of low and you'll
notice that the students the clinical
students identified when you compare the
2d maps between the two color maps so
the the new color map is the darker bar
the lighter bar is the rainbow color map
many compare these two you see there's a
difference from 91 percent of all loius
areas were identified in the 2d column
app and the 2d representation with the
diverging column map and only 62% were
identified in the superior condition of
the rainbow column I don't guess even
worse when we look at the 3d model with
the two different color maps 71% of all
lo ESS regions identified with the 3d
model and the diverging colomac and only
39%
% were identified with the 3d model and
the rainbow color map which is what
clinicians have been using and so as you
see there are statistical significant
differences in terms of the ability of
these questions to our medical students
to identify these areas and now the work
that were k.michelle working and we're
colleagues presented there is based on a
solid understanding of you know what
utilization is working which ones don't
work and that's what we can see that
there are indeed big big differences if
you do your job well when it comes to
visualization it matters so this is my
motivation to tell you a bit more about
how we can encode data and why it really
matters I'll get this right so here's a
very simple taxonomy of data I'm not
going to spend much time on it they
essentially start out with data can be
tabular data or debater and order data
itself can be ordinal or quantitative so
ordinal is simply ordered and we can
have categories and people over for
example in quantitative data we can also
do some algebra compute on it
additionally we have relational data
that means links such networks on trees
between different types of entities and
we also have spatial data so that means
spatial data is data that comes with an
intrinsic position within space whether
that's absolutely the relative doesn't
matter you can imagine for example the
locations atoms in a protein structure
MRI data spatial data and x-ray data
spatial data those kind of things are
special because they do have a
real-world representation everything to
the last of space is abstract data and
that's where we are completely free to
choose our encoding because there is no
real real world representation that we
wouldn't know of generally so I mean
it's relational data I can imagine you
know well on the other hand if you if
you talk about is like a road network
that is a spatial data it has some
relational aspects to it for example but
it's important to distinguish these two
things from each other and now we can
ask how can we encode data when we have
all these different parties so for
example we can start thinking about
categorical data you're asking the
questions like what is or or where's and
here um we can use a plane and place
items data types data points sorry
they're points for objects on a plane
and depending where we placed them that
assigns in the category so you can
imagine you're you know cleaning up your
desk in your office and you make three
piles of paper stuff that goes into
recycling stuff that need to be filed
and stuff that you really should have
done yesterday so there are three
categories very clearly distinguish them
from each other it's very easy to to
figure out what is what we can do the
same thing by assigning colors and then
this case what the yes you use it the
component of the color model here is
huge I have a commonly refer to this as
the color of an object shapes can be
used to encode categories and then we
can basically for these things and how
with respect to how accurately we could
recall that information but which
category was assigned to an object the
best or the most accurate encoding is is
really position and then you go to
shapes that gets very problematic at
some point when you go to shapes with
many many corners and that gets gets
pretty tricky to distinguish them from
each other for example the same with
colors and you'll get to that relational
data can be encoded for example by using
something called containment that can
put things that belong together into the
same area and things that not belong
there outside of that area I can use
connection which is what we typically do
no link diagrams for example or
similarity is another way to encode this
kind of data and again I'll use what
fourth option is to use proximity so
things that are closer to each other
belong together and things that are
along somewhere else are a further way
so again there is a way to or these I
think most obvious has become the most
obvious how how importance is when we
look at quantitative and ordinal data so
the most accurate way to to convey that
information in there which makes it easy
for us to recall student what is the
quantity or what is the value here is to
use positions on a common scale we can
also use positions on other lines
Gayle's so where we we have a origin of
the scale can move in space or on the
plane and we can use lengths of objects
we can use angle Tour tilt and maybe you
already start thinking about bar charts
and pie charts area can be used to
encode quantities curvature I've never
seen a really good visualization will
reduce curvature but it's possible
volumes are used very very awesome
unfortunately that is not a very good
encoding and remember the pca example
that I showed you the beginning that
I'll see used size of 3d spheres on a
flat screen lightness can be used so
basically how how light or dark how much
like that basically in the grayscale and
color the saturation is another option
but color saturation really is not a
good choice for quantitative data which
maybe you're thinking now Wow
you're using heat maps all the time for
example for gene expression data or
other similar data and yes we are using
that or lightness but you really not
should not be using this for any
quantitative data whatever you want to
encode or show with these things should
begin with qualitative again here's the
ranking and you can also then look
across these different ways though
different data types and different
encodings and you'll see it you know
depending on what you have certain
things will work other and other things
won't work as well so it's very
important to think about that in
coatings that you want to use when you
start working with date and I want to
give you one example just in a simple
example where we can see what a
difference that can make
so you must all be familiar with these
kind of diagrams where we're using
circles and numbers in them and
intersections of circles to encode some
some overlap of sets so this is from a
paper that was in Nature communications
it doesn't really matter is what's
called a Venn diagram turns out in fact
this is not a Venn diagram this is
actually earlier diagram it just like
difference in a Venn diagram you have
always you show all intersections that
are possible between your sets and in
all of the aya Graham you just show
those that actually exist
and so this example it is not a total
diagram sorry it's not a Venn diagram
diagram and when we try to interpret
data these days so first of all the
first question here's like let me just
ask you what is the biggest intersection
here and now what happens look at this
well there are a lot of numbers you
would sequentially go through and try to
find all of them than this one and try
to remember which one is the largest if
I would ask you sort of what is the
distribution our dataset like one really
big one and then it's sort of fizzling
out as a normally distributed or like
what sort of distribution to be see here
when you can try to do this but it's not
straightforward because again you need
to look at all the numbers inside
remember because this visualization does
not convey this so this is in fact is it
is a non area proportional diagram here
you can only make these Venn diagrams
area proportional so that the area
replica responds to the number written
in the area for up to three sets beyond
that you can even do that but the
problem here is what what even if they
would now look at these areas like what
we're using to encode the area is a
shape it's a but we're using to encode
the number or the number we're using an
area and these are all areas of even
like irregular shapes and other than all
the same it's not that they're all
circles which you can easily compare
they have all sorts of shapes here and
if you go back to this example here
right area is not a very accurate or
useful encoding for quantities this is
pretty much pretty far down bliss it's
even worse than angles which were using
one pie charts and all hopefully know
that hydros are not a good faith
representative so what can we do about
this so we need when we apply our
principles that I just talked about the
how to encode data we arrive at
something that looks like this for
example which is an offset plot where we
encode the size of the area oh it's
alright so the size of the intersection
in the length of a bar and then the
height of the bar so you can make the
bar chart and then just place the little
D bar chart the little matrix that shows
which of the sets involved are
intersecting and I can now easily answer
the question which one is the largest
intersection in fact it's not in a
minute section it's this case we're
looking at so much
or call that four different colors we
can see there's one call it generated an
awful lot of slips and none of the other
colors found this is a mic you know you
can also start organizing these bars and
in this bar chart out of the are free to
reorder them for example we can order
them rather than by size of the bar
between group them based on a number of
intersections that are participating
what number sets are participating in an
inception and here we see for example
well there's a lot of these largely in a
section to actually have two or three
sets in them there's the outlier with
one set of one nearest ones where they
will only have to give a single set and
the case when we're looking at all four
in a second one's actually pretty small
but this is just another example to show
you that when we apply the proper
encoding we generally and that with a
better visualization and defeating just
encode the data in a way that might be
looks tough okay now as you've seen we
often have many data types and many ways
to encode them and so how do we pick the
one in the encoding that's that's the
best or that's most effective here and
so there is something called the
principle of importance ordering when it
comes to thinking of coatings and that
says encode more important information
more effectively is something that
statement or a quote from a by Jack
McKinley or those who know tableau
software Jeff Macke and Lenin is a data
visualization researcher for many years
in an co-founded is very very successful
visualization of data analytics and his
level it's company but this he has done
very fundamental research in that area
and that probably one of the reasons why
they're so successful now ranking of
encoding so the first question to ask is
generally and how active they come to
think from the decision but there other
things to consider for example when you
talk about categories we want to be able
to discriminate them from each other if
you have lots of them we need to know
how many categories our encoding can
actually support so this criminality for
example is a question before we get down
pologize I want to also briefly show you
another example firfer
for the scenario where we're looking at
accuracy and and what kind of problems
we can run into this even if we have a
great employee so typical example we
have a table a bunch of items and we
have a couple of categories and now we
can ask all sorts of questions about
that for example you might ask you know
we might be interested in like so how do
what is the total value for each for
each item and like this and so this is a
stacked bar chart so that works pretty
well if you're primarily interested in
total now questions have become much
harder is for example to see what is the
contribution offs a category three to
each of these items now we're looking at
these green green areas or green sup
bars within this bar chart and well to
you know to know which one of those it's
a long something they're not very
different you can see this from the
table but one of them is longer actually
by three minutes than one of the others
so the first one for item 1 is the value
for the green one is 18 and for an item
5 the value for the third Academy is
only 15 but to see that is not that
straightforward
because these are not aligned to each
other and so this visualization might
work well if you're really primarily
interested in the total and that's the
key thing we want to know but if you
care more about you know what are the
contributions of the of these categories
across the items if you want to ask that
question we can now ask answer that
question very easily when we use
something called a layered bar chart
where we have multiple bar charts that
still went to convey somewhat you know
we could still tell maybe which one is
the largest one it's not easy but we can
try to sort of usually added up here but
if this this representation is much
better to see the distribution within
each Academy and finally there's also
this option to group bar chart where we
want to just know or where we care more
about how do these categories contribute
for each item like what is the
distribution of those are they're all
roughly the same or are they very
different and that can be achieved with
this group bar chart and the point I
want to make here is even that
inaccurate encoding is not gonna get you
a perfect answer there's always a
trade-off like this one where you need
to understand
only well what are the values that I
care about but also what is what is it
that ultimately you want to communicate
here and so well you can you can't have
it all unfortunately with visualization
there's very rarely an optimal solution
there are often acceptable solutions but
they will not answer all questions
perfectly well so in addition to the
accuracy of these alone coatings you can
look at channels about pre-attentive
process and so this is a little test I
hope this is going to work on this
webinar I'm gonna show you a couple of
slides where we have these little
visualizations where where we have
couple blue dots and there will be they
will flash up several times for about
250 milliseconds and sometimes there
will be erect a dot in there let what's
red circle and sometimes they're wrong
and for you just try to see whether you
can spot that red circle among the blue
circles as this is happening so let's
just try this real quick nothing nothing
there it is so I hope there's another
one I hope you are able to spot this
this is pretty easy because color is a
property that can be processed pretty
tentacley you remember this from the
very beginning when I showed you the
insulin sequins and asked you to look
for purlins so the color you can we can
really exploit the our ability to see
certain things without sequentially scan
the scene in front of us this is sort of
the idea that something jumps out at you
when you're when you're looking at it so
we can do the same thing with shapes and
circles do you think that's not a work I
see a lot of question marks and adds
more question marks over imaginary
people listening to this presentation
but let's give it a try
so I'll again flash these seams for 20
50 milliseconds and sometimes there will
be a red circle among the red squares
and sometimes they blow and let's see if
you can spot it just pay attention
did you see it there's another one so
the answer is you should be able to see
it I hope some of you did they it it is
known that shape is it property again
there can be process pre-attentive - and
now let's try one more thing
where we combine two it's impossible
until you so we can use shape and color
and do you think you'll be able to spot
the red circle among the blue circles
and red squares and for those who at
least saw the red circle among the red
squares you can be hopeful that you
might spot in here as well let's try
so you probably are disappointed because
it is not positive so once you start
combining different encodings different
channels bring 30 so she can color
pre-attentive processing breaks down it
no longer works that's something we'll
come back to at the very end of the
presentation as well
so that's something to keep in mind when
you're picking and trollee and also when
we can separate channels from each other
that's another problem so for example if
you have two very small areas by two
very small circles
we might not be able to tell what color
they are so that's something to need to
keep in mind if you combining words we
have a very very small circle and a very
very small rectangle often it's not
possible to really distinguish them so
these things break down at some point
okay now I'm being told I have to maybe
stand closer to the microphone up a
little works okay so what we're going to
talk about now our common mistakes when
picking and codings so the first step
here is to look at the colors and color
Maps rainbow color maps are all over the
place and I've already demonstrated that
they are not doing a good job
what is the problem with rainbow color
so first of all rainbow color Maps it's
there's no natural well there's a
national ordering that's a color to the
light spectrum it has a natural ordering
for the rainbow color map but it's not
something that we are intrinsically
aware of that
you know the colors are sort of in
grabbed orange yellow green blue indigo
violet that's something I have to think
about it and try to remember this nice
shortcut oh I keep it to do that so hard
to order it's not clear how they stick
you order look at the grayscale column
out it's very easy there are two
different ways of how you can order a
color map well you can order them in one
way and then you can say either dark is
the smallest value or darkest the
highest value and it's very clear what
how they are relative to each other
rainbow color maps have a problem with
resolution for example because our
ability to distinguish different we huge
from each other is much worse than say
distinguishing other like even lightness
contrast from each other we cannot see
this to sort of these little pattern
here that you're seeing this figure when
you look at the very top there is there
ripples but you don't see them in the
rainbow colored map because we cannot
distinguish these greens from each other
it has a lower resolution actually
although you'd think wow they're more
colors we can do
get better resolution but you can't the
same is true for artifacts so if they
encode say a linear function that you
know goes from 0 0 to 1 1 that sort of a
linear slope going up you can do this
with a grayscale very clear this is
linear slope going up if you use a
rainbow color map you start infusing
artifacts and it looks more like a sort
of a step function because you see sort
of red yellow green and and and that
looks nothing like the actual shape of
the curve that would just be a straight
line that's introduces steady other
problems waiting with color maps for
example it has not it doesn't have a
national 0 cross two built-in so if you
apply this to something where the zero
crossing is important you not see the
zero so here's an example of what
mapping is two elevations in the Gulf of
Mexico and Florida so you would not want
to use that rainbow colored map wearing
raw encoding to like determine like
weird a lot of third can worry enemies
because you simply can't see but just as
yellow across the board and that's why
we use different types of color maps
than 0 really matters
another thing to keep in mind is color
is relative and many of you that all of
you will remember the black and blue
dress over here the white and gold dress
depending on which one you saw in that
picture so we perceive color relative to
its environmental to its surrounding
colors and there are some examples for
example you can make two different
colors look the same in the middle like
this both rounds for the higher one the
one of the lower rectangle look the same
but when you put them actually Joe you
see they're not to see and we can do the
opposite we can take two identical
colors and make them look different by
changing the background color why does
it matter it matters because we're
constantly using heat maps turn code our
data particularly large and big data
sets and if you try to eat anything
quantitative all these maps to begin
with it's it's bound to fail because
it's very bad encoding as a shogi it's
not an accurate encoding and on top of
that we have to issue that colors that
might look different or the same are
actually often not because in depend on
the background color and the surrounding
colors so these two columns labeled with
an asterisk here are the same color same
value but they
totally different here it looks like a
large value larger value and he looks
like the lower value but is simply
because of the context of these
discriminability of colors as I point
out as a product so in general you can
assume six to twelve colors can be
discriminated but you often have to have
more categories and here's an example
where that fails like you see on the
left hand side of a mouse chromosomes
each mouse from say almost a sign of
color so they're 21 colors and then for
something sent in the mapping game or a
Mac on top of human chromosomes to see
which part of which Mouse from the same
end up in the tune from Excel and while
on the right hand side you can just tell
that they're 21 different colors you can
easily distinguish them from each other
there if you would go back now to the
human chromosomes picked a random green
area and try to map that back to the
mouse chromosomes this is most likely
gonna fail because there are we're not
able to distinguish the different greens
from each other the same holds true for
the blues as well which are very hard to
map back because they no longer next to
each other okay colorblindness is an
issue probably all familiar with this
many journeys luckily these days tell
authors do not send those you know that
green anything unless you have a dual
encoding where you use another variable
visual encoding to to distinguish
between because the colored lines will
not be able to tell the difference
between red and green for example in a
heat map so this on the left hand sides
you actually even have on the right hand
side is a simulation for possum of
technique toward lights which receive it
simply answer do business use blue and
red that can always be distinguished
color mapping again to come back a
similar to the problem with the rainbow
color map applied to elevation if you
have again a simple function simply
increases your it's all the values
between 0 and 10 so no zero crossing if
you start mapping a a color map
diverging column at that for example has
White's
between blue and Red's will create
artifacts because there is nothing the
way if you map as you can see the C at
the bottom it's sort of darker darker
it's getting very dark I'm getting light
and lighter and then suddenly it's
getting darker again so you would think
that potentially the shape of this curve
is something like those
and goes up and goes down again but this
is not the case and by anything
particularly by adding light in between
you can create heat maps it look like
there are striking features that are
staying out and unfortunately include an
example here but there is no such thing
it's simply a linear increase but
because we go through white that will
make a very strong color contrast and
that can be very very misleading so
here's a couple of examples for a better
color mannequins okay so to remember
colleges poorly is worse than no color
at all and with this I think what I'm
going to do I want to tell you a little
bit more about the d3 problems as these
3d problems and that is shown this slide
so we are awesome working or sort of
faces like Oh couldn't you make it
three-dimensional because we have maybe
three different variables to show I mean
my answer is no you cannot make it
three-dimensional and the reason why you
cannot make it three-dimensional and
what it generally does not work is the
following so here is an example a little
bit of DNA and you perceive it as
something three-dimensional on your
screen and the reason for this because
we applying something called depth depth
cues so there's occlusion like something
in front it's closer to you or in front
will be closer to you than something
behind it so that's hid there's
something so something is hidden we do
see differences in size of the same
object and when we see that let me know
there's something that's smaller but the
same object this bigger closer is closer
to us we can see shading so shading is
when there's a light source things that
are further away or facing away from the
light source plane will be darker than
things that are facing the light source
additionally we use something of
perspective which you're all familiar
with which just means essentially
parallel lines which meet each other in
the distance that's another indicator
that we're looking into some
three-dimensional scene and now they're
using all these things using science
shading in color the the directionality
of lines your perspective now all these
things are things are usually used to
encode data and that can lead to a lot
of problems when we try to encode data
using exactly the same kind of encoding
or the same
of channels that we use to make
something look 3d so here's an example I
want sorry the example is coming up here
I don't want to go into much detail sort
of a three-dimensional heat map which
encodes additional values for example
here you see problem number one we have
perspective that means there's
distortion so things that are closer to
us will naturally appear taller and
larger than things that are further away
so we can be careful with that another
problem that we see here is that of
course when there's something tall in
front of us now in the 3d scene we can't
look through it so that will be
occlusion things will be hidden behind
other things otherwise it won't appear
as 3d and so there are many many issues
like that so it is generally not a good
idea to go to 3d because it will cause
more problems than it's worth
occlusion here another example is a 3d
network representation so you could
imagine you know this does blogger in
the top right we don't know what's
behind it it's we know it's 3d but in
order to look behind it we have to start
rotating this thing and rotating is work
and visualization should not create more
work it should produce them right that's
what I said in the beginning should
allow us to use our perceptual system to
see things and perceive things and to
make us more efficient and not to add
additional manual labor to the process
interpreting the data here's another
example for occlusion and perspective I
would ask you what is the pattern in the
data are hard to answer this
from this perspective so if the encode
is differently say using the heat map so
see the pattern is actually pretty
straightforward
that is the pattern it's a big question
ok so that's a bunch or these are a
bunch of issues you can run into and you
pick the wrong with codons well I want
to move towards the end of my
presentation and talk briefly about
visualization for communication so my
first point that I want to make this
when we use visualization to communicate
something thinks of this crowd here in
this in this lecture we're often
communicate
by putting the figure into a paper and
so my answer to that is put the insights
and into your figure in the paper but
put your data into database so when you
going to create figures we're asking you
feeling you need whether this is our
sort of that is coming directly out of
our heart to show what we've done or
whether it's our PII or someone else
telling us we need to show all these
things to convince leader I would say
this is not a bad and not a good idea so
day I belong some to database people
came to me should not just try to
visualize everything and you know
there's no point in having a full page
heat map because in the end it's a
qualitative pattern but Austin can be
represented much better than just
showing like oh you're all these things
that we didn't already generated I think
that belongs to the database and it is
important to really focus on the message
this is wrong job inviting the paper
it's to communicate clearly what we
found and even when it involved data
that can be done so here's an example
that I want to want to give you there
are a couple of numbers and you know
when we look at these numbers so data
right we can interpret this in many
different ways for example right so we
could look at these numbers and ask
ourselves well does it matter that
they're you know the values in the first
row are all odd and the values in the
second are all even is that is that the
point of this visualization we don't
know so let's try this differently right
so now we bend the values and you know
we're trying to would be really trying
to get across here there's something
that you'll see at the very end but now
we've been to values
we're using sort of aggregations we have
three categories now of our values so
here 0 and 30 between 31 16 between 61
and 100 now now we have these bins right
so it's the same data but they have
thought they're in three different
categories essentially and now we can
ask well is the order of the values
actually important here is that what
we're trying to learn from this data
visualization that there are some
ordering of these things
not so if it's not then why don't we
sure like this so we have three
categories and we have their size and
now we can see if that's clear but
probably now we start wondering do we
really need to show the distribution of
the values in each way or do we just
care about number of elements in this
category which something like this so
here are 4 visualizations of exactly the
same data and each of them can lead to a
completely different interpretation of
what is the message that you're trying
to get across in this case you're the
message that we want to get across is
there are relatively few values in the
middle range here so there are very few
between an Academy 31 to 6 that is the
message and that is very clear right so
we have nothing that distracts us from
that we're not distracted by any order
or by any specific values which we can
seems very cool during this example so
we're going from something very
unfocused where we could interpret all
sorts of things into the day into the
visualizations or something that is very
very focused on the message and that is
very important so there's another more
data-driven example you know when you
when you have something like gene
expression data you can always plot a
few map and that's what always is
happening because they even have a sort
of a very Universal approach again a big
number of of the genes for example and a
good number of conditions plot it and
you can cluster mijita mobile you post
across and even then it can bring out
some patterns but it is not very helpful
when you have you know a thousand or
five thousand rows and you're leaving
that because there will be over plotting
those you look at on the screen the
screen has about a thousand two thousand
pixels maybe maximum height that you can
even even distinguish on each other so
in that case if you have that min values
you make me care more about sort of
generally what clusters are there and
then something like a you know
dimensionality reduction approach could
work much better because it brings out
the clusters more clearly and maybe
death should be your message in that
case but you want to really show all
your data that there are a number of
clusters because then the profiles you
cannot make them out anyways so that's a
solution for many
profiles but lower resolution is less
information of course and indemnity
reduction on the other end of the
spectrum on the Left we have very few
profiles and maybe maybe want to
indicate there are some real and subtle
differences or have you ever care really
about the shape of these profiles we can
use a parallel coordinate or line plot
that we can get the message across there
but we have a lot of downsides there
because there it's over bonding
happening when there are too many of
these lines and Pugh becomes even hard
to follow the lines but that's something
you need to in mind the same thing is
true for networks so this is a no link
diagram representation of the network so
network is simply a graph data structure
it's is something that has not a
necessarily a visual representation and
then you plot them as this example you
know link diagram for every node in the
graph is a there's a circle and then
when your alliance between the circles
when they're connected in the graph if
you care about the connectivity of
individual notes mainly the circular
layout is good you just order some
circle or the notes base and have
connected their yards or other nodes in
a network you can see that there are
about maybe good order of them or how
you connect it well in the other layout
is force-directed layout we get much
better focus on like which ones are
highly connected among themselves in a
[ __ ] mode is a hub so a central node in
here to pick your layouts correctly and
we should also never forget that and
that word doesn't have to be rendered as
a node length diagram that's one way to
look at it you can also look at it like
as an adjacency matrix where we can see
different things for example in the
adjacency matrix you don't have a
problem lines crossing each other we can
still here on the right-hand side and on
the bottom right you can see very nicely
that there are is a clustered highly
connected nodes in this network you can
also see this top at the top this green
node in the top left plane which has a
lot of connections to other nodes which
among themselves are not necessarily
connect the downside of the adjacency
matrix is very hard to trace the path
between say two notes that are not
necessary directly directly connected we
need to answer that question is this a
hard work in a node is easily fairly
easy in a no link diagram but it's
really much much harder in a annamund
Jason C matrix we can use in
communication you should also always
remember
that's how we lay out information or
data in front of the user can can convey
a message here we have four things that
are sort of equal they have equal weight
there is no clear order into this maybe
you could say I'll have to get into it
so you could interpret some sort of over
here this is pretty much the same thing
that I already explained to you let's
focus on the message right so we can use
goosed outlaws to convey this so here
are two pairs of things that we compare
to each other right now by simply moving
the middle closer to each other and
leaving a larger gap between two groups
here we have something that a sequential
go problem from left to right therefore
steps or for ten points that is
important to think about that in your
visualizations and representations like
what is it that you want to come back
well and to go back to this of course if
you publishing a journal there's always
a problem that well there's not enough
space to contain it so but keep that in
mind there's sometimes a way about it
another thing is to you know not overly
used color there's something called the
data in ratio so your data uses little
to maximize this data to ink ratio
you'll get much better figures that are
not distracting but focus on the data
and finally don't shout at your audience
I'm like I'm doing this right now
take it back try to think about what is
important what is the message we want to
get across to reduce for example color
and unnecessary embellishments like
making a 3d effect or drop shadows if
your message is simply to say well there
are two things the A's and the B's that
leads to what the outcome is for your
answer so there's a big difference when
you compare these two slides that I just
showed you here I think you get a much
better idea what the message might be
and with that I'm just want to come back
to my store so that the starting point
here is dialogue between computer
analysts in something where we need as
much data as possible because we do not
know what the story is that we might
want to communicate at some point so
that's what we want to have access to
almost all the data in the world you
could get
but that is not true when you go to
present this to someone out there you
start out with all the data you can get
your hands on you use visualization
other data analysis approach is to come
with some insight something that you've
learned about your data and then when
you communicate if you strip it down to
only the data it is necessary to get
that message across so that is maybe the
big take-home message of my presentation
today and hopefully the different kinds
of approach is to figure out how to
visualize data will help you next time
they try to come up with a good data
visualization Linux for exploration or
for communication upon summation thank
you very much No thank you that was a
really outstanding overview of many of
the things that people should be
watching for as they're trying to
communicate the message of their
large-scale data and especially as we
collect more and more of it we need
effective ways to concisely present that
information to an audience that they may
not fully understand the scale and scope
of that big data but we want to get
those messages across and I was curious
cuz it at the sort of end of your
presentation you had talked about the
data to ink ratio and I know that dr.
Tufte has been one of the biggest
advocates for that can you make us some
further comments about the importance of
that and helping to streamline one's
graphics to make sure that they don't
violate that or what are some kind of
rules of thumb that one might use right
so um for example I can the very one
example is when you when you create a
bar chart alright so think about you
know is is doesn't matter but if each
bar is a separate category you know
you're already by separating the bars
you need to put color on top of each of
these bars this is pretty much example
that I showed you just now where know we
probably don't need to put color on each
of these bars because that's all we
wanted to sing worship from each other
and that's that's taking place simply by
having four Shepherd bars now a
different story here could be if you do
have a second variable that we
want that we care about so here where's
April May June July
maybe we care about the fact that in
April let's let's let's mark the months
when we had a snowstorm which don't
happen in Boston this year but then you
would have like months with us no sir
let me we'll do two colors to maybe
indicate snow for when there's no story
on top of these bars so you really don't
include any any unnecessary things or if
someone asks you what does that mean and
you don't have an answer then remove it
so and you should really remove ask
yourself that question about almost
everything you're everything you put in
your visualization why is it there it
has to have a reason to be there
otherwise it's an unnecessary
embellishment like 3d effects in fact 3d
effects can be pretty harmful because
you get darker colors for example at the
bottom of the bar and they get lighter
towards the top so we always like if
there if you really care about the
values in lengths of these bars and but
but even got the colors at the bottom
they might draw more attention to the
bottom of the chart rather than to the
top where actually the difference is all
that we might want to highlight so there
is a really wide range of sort of
mistakes that we tend to make often
because tools suggest that we make that
mistake right so if you make a standard
bar chart in any of the many say
spreadsheet programs out there it'll
generally not take you know
this manager to maximize the data to ink
ratio into account it'll give you nice
colors for whatever reason there is
probably a good reason in other words
but as scientists and maybe science
communicators really want to be accurate
and I think for us the sort of the need
to make our visualizations exciting so
there people look at them it's often not
even there it's often not a reason for
that because people will look at the
data because they do care about it it's
not something that we need to convince
them to look at the bar chart in our
paper that's this this they have a
natural inclination to look at it
because they want to know what you did
it's different if you're trying to go
out into the world
and draw attention to a problem in the
world then it there's there's more of a
reason to think about how do we get
attention but I would argue that
attention getting attention is always
second to getting data across as
accurately as possible and I think it's
like the right point you Alton yeah
that's a great point for us to end on
and because we're at the top of the hour
I want to thank everybody in our
audience for for joining us today and
Nils I want to thank you for giving us a
very useful guide of how to represent
our data graphically and in our papers
for maximum effect and I want to
encourage everybody to tune in next week
when we have a actually we actually next
week we will not be having one our
speaker had a health concern and so has
had to cancel on us we'll try and find
another time to schedule something with
that speaker in the future but for next
next week we will not be having one of
our data science seminar series my deep
apologies for that but at any rate I
hope that we'll see you again in the
future so thank you everybody and thank
you nill thank you very much